Kim Kardashian steps out for the second
night in a row and calls Rob and blac
Chyna's relationship unstable as Kylie
Jenner calls out a dangerous trend and
kendall has a girls night out
Kanye West rocked Los Angeles for a
second tonight Wednesday and Kim was
there to cheer her hubby on the star
shied away from photographers though
she's still keeping a low profile after
the Paris robbery but mom Kris Jenner
and her boyfriend Cory gamble were
snapped by photog entering the concert
so someone just tweeted me one of
gloominess gloomy people meanwhile Kylie
Jenner is warning fans and not to buy a
lip kits from anywhere but her website
and big sis Kendall spent her Wednesday
night at the Lakers game with model
bestie Karlie Kloss
and finally here's a preview of this
week's Keeping Up with the Kardashians
in which Kim is very confused by brother
Rob deleting all his Instagram posts
again I just don't even know what to say
I know that Rob and Chyna had like an
unstable relationship there's obviously
two sides to every story and you know
they just know how to push each other's
buttons and my brother just like shuts
down
you